what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time on Friday
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest though it's just trying to get her
lunch money right I'm here with the
beautiful and intelligent plenum era
Nova I didn't know today was lunch when
he goes on the Prairie
today you literally you look like you
should be in a stage Paige in a stage
you should be back there with your head
evany please take me to the general
store and you t know go get your own
store all right don't forget lunch one
is now sponsored by block bi use the
link in the description sign up between
now and July 18th if you sign up you
will get two x - 1 2 X the amount of
interest normally you can get up to
eight point six percent interest on
their interest-bearing account but if
you sign up and fund the account before
July 18th
they're running this ridiculous special
that will give you 2 X the interest rate
for the month of August
go do it what's going on right Red
Riding Hood no no ok
Vivian raise did you say can you say it
in an English accent forcefully no cuz
my British accent sounds like southern
oh this could be a southern outfit oh
yeah yeah but then my southern accent
sounds it's a very welcome to making
North Carolina
oh good what's going on Vivian raises
two point five billion dollars in an
aggressive plan to beat Tesla and be
among the first if not the first company
to bring an all-electric pickup to
market early next year can rivey in' do
it maybe I don't know I kind of like
ravine there was a really good profile
on the company and I like that they're
kind of understated but they don't seek
the spotlight but then here we are
raising 2.5 billion and fresh funding I
think Andreessen
well recent do it no sorry not
increasing Amazon ray put in some money
last year
so did Ford last year soren so they
raised 2.5 billion dollars last year
amazon t rowe Price Cox Automotive for a
bunch of people put money in they just
raise another 2.5 billion so now they've
raised over five billion dollars it's an
automaker it's really really really hard
to start a car company I have a question
yes do we think that Cox automotive and
Ford and I was on I think do we think
everybody's just trying to team up to
beat Tesla um to some degree sure but
you have to remember like first you got
to be able to produce the cars as we see
what esle like it's really hard to do
Tesla has done it Tesla also has the
brand but to me the more interesting
thing around this whether it's Nikola
which is another electric car company
its Tesla right I don't know why they
had to choose our last name at first and
or Rivi in is at the end of the day what
really ends up happening is electric
vehicles are here to stay like this is
the future right the gas-guzzling cars
of yesteryear are going to go away
yesteryear come from well you do look
like that like what's your horse's name
and so I just think that like raising
billions of dollars is necessary in
order to make this work and we'll see
what happens like it's pretty cool how
they think that they can do it and the
other thing too is like Amazon's already
pre-ordered a hundred thousand of these
from River yeah it's not just for Bezos
I see you Joe it's further it's for
logistics I will say though I think a
horse and carriage what did you call me
a stagecoach is much more efficient than
any of these vehicles okay if if
somebody had asked what's the saying if
somebody had asked if Henry Ford had
asked what a customer's want they would
have said a faster horse yeah instead
this is I think this is the future so I
think I think the big race is gonna be
how long does it take tests let it get
to the pickup truck they're going with
the cyber truck the cyber trucks [ __ ]
why why is the truck why does a pickup
truck such a big deal is it because like
in guzzles just a lot of gas and it's
hard to make no it's just I think
Tesla's got like a very strong
choke hold on kind of a sports car right
and so somebody else could come up with
one sure and so the existing incumbent
manufacturers are going to but two or
three of the big areas are like multi
passenger like van / minivan like that
type of stuff
pickup trucks because pickup trucks
obviously Ford f-150 is one of the best
selling cars of the entire car industry
right because it's got so many use cases
and the other one is 18 wheelers right
and kind of very large type things there
and so if you want to sell a lot of cars
one of the best places to do is to
target the pickup truck man if you can
if you can crack the soccer mom van
situation I don't you win I actually
don't think that's as big of a market as
the truck if I remember correctly and I
may be wrong somebody correct me in the
comments if I am but I believe that the
Ford f-150 is the best-selling car in
America which is a pickup truck okay
okay question I see a lot of pickup
trucks in the south and it's they're
driven by a lot of you know southern men
do we think they're gonna want this
sleek ass like yeah luxurious they are
going hunting they don't want this yes
they do how do you know because they're
gonna like it you think yeah people like
nice things they like shiny things yeah
but when you go hunting you know hunting
this that's fine we have your little
hunting beater truck and then you can
have this that's fine what's going on
with kwibi are they out of money yet
okay so maybe the short-form video app
founded by Jeffrey Katzenberg and Meg
Whitman has retained just 8% of
customers who signed up for a 90 day
free trial according to a new research
study now it's important because kwibi
immediately came out with a press
release saying that the number of paid
subscribers is incorrect by an order of
magnitude pushing back on the data and
say they added that over 5.6 million
people have downloaded the kwibi app as
opposed to sensor towers 4.5 million
estimate what we tell you guys when
raising this for years
when you raise too much money you can
kill yourself as a business because
you don't know if you have product
market fit they don't have product
market fit this is what they didn't even
test it
they incentivized people to download it
on these free trials they got 5 million
people to download by the way that's not
that much but they claim victory they
got 5 million people to download this
thing when they did that only 8% of
people state 92% of people did not
convert to give you an idea I would be
really impressed they converted 50% that
would be 50 or more percent of the free
trial would be like ok there they got a
shot they can optimize and get it up to
60 70 80 % average in my opinion would
be kind of 25 to 35 maybe 40 percent
that would be kind of ok this is down
the fairway 8 percent is only one word
to describe 8 percent conversion of a
free trial pathetic if pathetic if I
woke up tomorrow and 92% of my profile
subscribers were gone I'd be like what
have I done
yeah well it's just it's obvious that
you gave them a free trial
they tried your product and they left so
92% of people think it's not worth
paying for there's not product market
and they're just lighting money on fire
letting billions of dollars on fire and
it's not going to work this was the
easiest thing in the world to tell one
of my favorite stories that I've heard
is during the development time at one
point Jeffrey Katzenberg was talking
internally at the company about Jane
Fonda workout videos and he basically
they're so popular yeah and he and he
was talking about all of this content
and the young here that work they're
like dude are you on the internet like
tick tock is hot right like it's not a
comparison
tick tock has mopped the floor with
movie could be couldn't even go get tic
TOCs food and rubbish beat everything
the name kwibi
quick bites ok I don't know I I just
think it's it's because you have people
who are out of touch with reality who
are trying to do this this is the
equivalent today there's two types of
marketing that happens there's the mad
men style let's put on our suits and
ties and go back in the room and we'll
smoked our cigars and drink our whiskey
and I will be so smart that I will come
up with the ad campaign that will take
over the world
yeah or you have people who say yo I'm
not that smart but watch this I'm gonna
create a hundred different variations of
ads I'm gonna put them on Facebook I'm
gonna put all this little spin behind
them and I'm gonna let the crowd tell me
what the best ad is and when I see one
of them working better than the rest I'm
gonna shut all the other ads off now I'm
gonna slam as much of my ad spend behind
that one ad and every convertible people
I the iteration data-driven software
based model will always win when I first
started the profile I think it was you
who gave me the best advice which was
like done is better than perfect
essentially because I just kept waiting
and waiting and waiting you wanted to
get it perfect for people to like it and
he was like just put it out there and
get the feedback and that was invaluable
because now when I look back at the
first iteration of the profile there's
no way I would have gotten here without
people's feedback done is done is better
than perfect you know why why because
perfection is the enemy of progress just
call me a modern-day cliche Seneca 8
1850 called it once its cliches back
what's going on ticked I wouldn't know
tick-tock okay so take two lacks
anesthesia that's not even relevant oh
yeah it is okay so talk is moving fast
it is considered breaking things no it
is considering changes to distance it's
app from its Chinese roots by creating
they're just discussing these options
supposedly but they're discussing
creating a new management board for
tick-tock or establishing a headquarters
for the app outside of China does it
matter does it matter
tick-tock is not going to be able to
convince people it doesn't have Chinese
roots and it's not susceptible to the
Chinese government actually they took it
off the App Store in Hong Kong now yep
that's why they passed the National
Security Law in Hong Kong that
completely stripped Hong Kong of its
sovereignty and all of a sudden tick
tock is no longer available in honk
you can tell me all you want you can
release all the press releases you want
you can leak stuff to the media you can
do all this stuff at the end of the day
I'm will watch your actions would what
would tik-tok do without its American
customer base user base I actually don't
think the u.s. customer base is that
important really like it's important in
the sense that I think Charlie D'Amelio
who is the American yet they have very
large audiences but from a user base
standpoint like India just bandit had
200 million Tik Tok users so that would
be like every 2 out of every 3 people in
the United States every single person
man woman child elderly etc having tick
tock on their phone right and so the
u.s. on an aggregate numbers basis for
an app that has almost 2 billion people
have downloaded it the u.s. is pretty
small to other places boy but Charlie do
million dicks on sale yes honey all
those people a lot of the most famous
stars are American and so we'll see what
happens but at the end of the day a a
very smart move they did was they hired
the guy from Disney to come in and be
the CEO Jacques of course they now have
an American dude running tick tock who
comes from Disney are you yawning did
you take a nap would you like to go out
into the Sun on your stagecoach and take
a nap you just you didn't finish your
costume you should put a hat on by the
way I'm still trying to figure out if
she got if this is like a costume or and
it's supposed to be funny or she like
legitimise gonna wear this today oh this
is like your real outfit for the day
what am I gonna go it's only you who's
gonna see me so enjoyed this yeah well
we're gonna make sure this outfit never
leaves the house I can't be seen on the
street with somebody we're gonna think
I'm a time traveler all right what's
going on with the robot butchers long
tick tock short kwibi robot butchers so
watchers or butchers what did I say
butchers how do you say it butcher
butchers
um butchers if you have butchers ma'am
you gonna have to let us look at the
robot butchers here we can't be having
these machines cutting up bodies animal
the animals gotta have a say in their
own lives come on let's go what's going
on and you're making fun of me okay so
you know I we talked about how Kovan
accelerated a lot of trends that were
already happening
um Tyson is now turning to robot
butchers spurred by a co bid and it's
speeding meat packers shift from human
meat cutters to automated once but
machines can't yet match people's
ability is it because of the precision
and you know that's gonna change very
quickly
I am manufacturing and supply chain is
all gonna get robots what ends up
happening is the US economy chased
efficiency and gave up resiliency
meaning that we want to be as efficient
as possible but it left us susceptible
to a whole bunch of things both in terms
of relying on other countries for supply
chain and manufacturing and also our you
again you're gonna have a young George
is very exciting that's fun well the
robots will cut you up and they're
practicing right now
oh and so what's gonna end up happening
is in order to get a more resilient
supply chain and manufacturing we're
going to have to bring things back on
shore we're gonna have to reinvest in a
bunch of American manufacturing all this
kind of stuff one of the things would be
Tyson Foods and what they're doing but
ultimately American labor is really
expensive and so what you're gonna see
is you're gonna have to capture the
deflationary nature of robotics and
technology and you're gonna start
replacing the American worker with
robotics and so yeah at the beginning
they're not going to be as good as the
humans but that's just give it a little
time what's interesting is that a lot of
the designers designing these robots are
coming from the auto industry which
makes sense because that's a highly
precision heavy
what do you call the dicks dextrous
thing to make auto parts so can you
imagine a robot with knives like like do
we think do we think have you ever seen
the one of Gordon Ramsay there's a video
online of Gordon Ramsay he's got a
blindfold on and he walks up to a
chicken like a full chicken and he
blindfolded takes a knife and he there's
a very specific way to
break down the chicken into all the
different parts and he doesn't
blindfolded like super quick you think a
robot can do that I don't think so
what's going out the inventors inventor
inventor so inventors a twelve-year-old
girl won a twenty thousand dollar prize
for creating an alarm to prevent hot car
deaths so when she was 10 years old she
was really alarmed by all these kids
being left in hot cars and she said it's
not even just about negligent parents
it's just it was happening way too often
and she said at first I thought about
raising money for the families but that
wouldn't fix the problem I wanted to
invent something that could prevent the
deaths from happening so she created a
device that it's triggered when it
senses the weight of the child and the
temperature setting reaches over 102
Fahrenheit anyway she did it two years
look at that oh so I have two thoughts
on this that are actually opposing views
one this is cool I'm glad she did this
too
technically it doesn't seem to be that
difficult in the sense of when you first
told me that somebody created it the
first thing I thought was okay you need
two core components you need something
that detects whether the core seat has a
baby in it or not and then you need
something to detect temperature okay and
so to me what's actually the cooler part
is not the technical solution because
it's one of those things were like if
you said to any engineer like hey let's
let's figure this out they probably
could figure it out she's 12
well the fact that she's 12 fine but I'm
not an ageist I don't care if you're 12
or 72 like let's just build things what
is the fact that like she was smart
enough to identify the problem and like
oh I want to solve that specific right
and so I think a lot of breakthroughs
like it's actually just taking the
mental energy and identifying the
problem and then focusing on it yeah and
then in hindsight of course it's obvious
like okay all we have to do is figure
out is there a baby and what's the
temperature yeah but see she did it
other people haven't done it thank you
again I think it's super cool like the
fact that she only won $20,000 I think
that they should give her away more
money she stole millions no president
sorry okay
so Lydia is her name she said don't
think that you have to accept things in
the world if there's something that
bothers you think of ways to make it
better
I love that yeah Lydia you're 12 wait
till you find a she's gonna be a
significant other in life when things go
wrong sometimes you can't make it better
sometimes you're just stuck with
somebody from the 1850s
what's going on with Mars you need to
improve your manners if I might say so
myself from the 1850s yeah I wouldn't
survive in the 1850s
you know what I would be I would be the
outlaw I'd be that going out at high
noon meet you there at high noon and
then you'd fight over me no yeah you'd
be like who's that in the pretty dress
no okay so the off drinking riding my
horse NASA's Curiosity rover is on a
road trip on Mars it is climbing farther
up a mountain to learn more about the
planets history and whether it could
have been habitable for microbial life
and attention there's water on Mars we
still on Mars I didn't know that thing
was still ' I saw up there
I thought we brought her back there's
water on Mars of course there was life
of course like some pointers because it
has all the conditions that are needed
for - I know humans I don't see no
beings well there was no humans before
humans got here either you understand
that's how evolution works where did we
come from
look at that camp do you really not know
no like on earth you don't know where we
came from yes I did we're from
Mesopotamia oh no no no well that's
Earth what do you mean where were we
before we were on earth no we evolved Oh
we were the microbial beings well first
of all we're all energy so yes we came
from some form of energy that evolved
into what we know it today as humans but
also on top of that you do realize that
we evolved from like orangutangs
and gorillas and monkeys and those types
of I am critter Liam - we may be having
a history lesson later today
household what if I take the religious
view what you gonna do then well I think
we were just plopped well that's fine
but do you believe science yes okay he
is he shook right now I love I'm not
shaking oh I'm just I just don't want to
say anything that upsets people but at
the same time I just believe in science
in that I believe that by the way I
don't think those two but but here's the
thing why did we evolve into such
complex beings that can wear this
beautiful dress whereas other micro
wheel beings did not evolve in such a
way and they're so dumb
what do you mean they were they weren't
close sometimes no yeah they do what do
you think a lion's mane is it's um in
some animals they just shed like a snake
just sheds it
we sheds we shed yeah but like a snake
can shed its skin right we shed skin all
the time do you know how whales breathe
through their little had a fish breathe
through their gills had a Hawks breathe
through their beaks all right I think
we've bored the people people are you
bored oh yeah they're just wait just
actually no you stay here and wait for
the people to respond to you and I
always come back later
no I got a joke no why okay ready yeah
all right this is done by the way she
aways google's funny jokes they're not
funny what's the best thing about
Switzerland what's the best thing about
Switzerland yep mm-hmm
it always stays in the middle no but I
would have been an okay one I don't know
but the flag is a big plus you think
that's funny yes come on up I don't
think it's funny at all actually I
actually literally didn't even have a
single reaction it's not funny I like
oh my god okay should we tell the people
that we will not be attending guys we're
not gonna be your Monday and Tuesday
sorry no lunch money Monday or Tuesday
that's sad
are you sad I'm not I need a break
I need a break I'm taking a break taking
a me day will let you know where we went
on Wednesday come back next Wednesday
see you for the weekend lunch money time
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get her lunch
money right bang bang hopefully plana
doesn't go back in time and now good
happened in the in the gold Age in the
gold a gold rush gold rush yeah alright
see you guys bang bang hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of lunch money as
much as we did don't forget lunch
money's now sponsored by block five so
go check them out there's a link in the
description that you can click on I'm an
investor a user and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block fire than
you are of me block wise my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block bye subscribe to
our channel like the video annoy plane
in the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends